(intense music)
(screams)
- Vegas baby.
- The Try Guys are throwing
a surprise bachelor party
for our best buddy Keith.
- By spending none of our own money.
- We work for Buzzfeed, it
is a major media company
and if we can't exploit that
for one of our best friends
Bachelor parties, then what's the point?
- [Eugene] Keith over here.
That's Brian, that's his brother, say hi.
- Hi.
(dings)
- [Keith] Can I take the bag off yet?
- No, you can't take the bag off,
Keith has no idea what's about to happen
because we are gonna
take him on the biggest,
(men scream)
baddest,
(men shout)
most expensive bachelor party
of all time!
- We're getting coconuts.
- And it's all happening in Vegas.
- Vegas baby.
- What happens in Vegas
gets put on the internet.
(upbeat music)
(screams)
- Are we going on a plane?
We get a fucking plane!
- The airplane the Try
Guys are flying on today
is valued at $6000.
- It's a cake.
- It's a private jet with
an app, check out my phone,
I went beep-boop-bop-beep,
got a private jet.
- It was a 5 minute flight out to Vegas.
- I've been to Vegas five times.
I don't remember any of it.
- I've been to several bachelor parties
but never in Vegas.
The crown jewel of dirty guy things.
- And look who's with us.
Oh.
- Thanks for getting my private jet lag.
- It is our job as best friends, to throw
an absolutely debacherous
weekend, filled with mistakes,
regrets and hangovers.
- [All] First private
jet, first private jet,
first private jet.
- So the first thing that
people do when they fly
on a private jet is drink a lot of booze.
- [Eugene] Free booze,
free booze, free booze.
- And take a lot of dumb pictures.
- [Ned] We literally
delayed the plane 15 minutes
just so we could take pictures.
- [Zack] You get a nice crew
that's going to take care
of handling your luggage,
beautiful airplane
with free booze in it, water, sodas.
- Mystery whiskey.
- Even the seat belts are gold.
- So our company does a lot
of really high net worth
executives, business people mostly.
- I've been farting all over this plane.
(laughs)
- Oh no!
(men shout)
- It's faster than most planes!
(engine roars)
- I've never seen Eugene actually nervous.
- I'm not nervous.
- He's so nervous.
(laughs)
Why do you still have your seatbelt on?
- Shut up, shut the fuck up.
- Wa-boom, chicken and waffles.
(laughs)
- Chicken Watch.
- [Try Guy] Anybody
else want some chicken?
- [Men] Cheers.
- I mean I got chicken, I got
a private jet, I got my boys,
it's pretty good.
- Private jet, we'll
see you in Vegas, bow.
- We are landing in Las Vegas, Nevada.
- Nevada, it's Nevada.
(men grumble)
I don't care but Nevadan's will get upset.
- You say Nev-ada, I say Nevada.
- [All Sing] Nev-ada,
Nevada, Nev-ada, Nevada,
- We're in Las Vegas.
I love that all of Vegas,
looks like different areas
of a theme park.
Oh hey, look at all these boys!
- So it's not just the Try
Guys on this bachelor party.
We got a whole big crew
we're rolling with.
Roll call.
- I've got two of my buddies
from Chicago, LP and Chris.
I got Alex and Hughie from
my comedy band Lou Burger.
Brian and Marc who are two of
my best friends from college
who also live in LA, my brothers
there, Try Guys are there
and then Chris Reinacher, it's a party.
I know it's hard to keep
it a secret, but it's also
hard for me not to be in control.
As you can see by me grabbing
my shoulder in stress.
- So Keith, we're
actually, we're not going
to a regular hotel.
- Uh-huh.
- We're uh, there's a private entrance.
- The Villas at the Mirage.
How do we know it's real?
If it's a Mirage?
What?
(cash register dings)
- [Nicholas] - Welcome to
the villas at the mirage.
- There's only eight places to
stay in this enormous castle?
And this is it?
- [Nicholas] Welcome to your villa.
- Holy shit.
- Let me take you to
where the magic happens.
- Very forward Nic.
Oh my god.
- So this is one of two bedrooms.
Dual masters, with dual
master baths as well.
- Those bathrooms are both
bigger than my apartment.
- The toilet, is a fucking square.
Open toilet.
- This is our own special
linen that we use here.
- Yeah.
- Different from the rest of the hotel.
- So the other commoners
don't get this fancy linen?
- Not this fancy.
- Just fancy folks like you and me?
- That's it.
- Alright Nic.
What are you doing for
the rest of this weekend?
(laughs)
Look up, smile.
(camera clicks)
- [Nicholas] And we didn't
even get to see the best part.
- There's a best part?
(men shout)
There's a tiny pool.
What and a big duck!
I did not think my day would
start out with a private jet
that leads to me being in
my underwear on a duck.
It's like gorgeous.
- Its nice being on a bed that's only
six inches off the floor,
know what I'm saying?
- All of our rooms do come
with their own private butler service.
We have a dedicated staff, dedicated chef,
so any order that you make is
coming right from our kitchen.
We'll send runners all
across the United States
all over the world
sometimes just to pick up
special requests for guests.
- Wait if I wanted like
Squirt, but I wanted Squirt
from South Carolina, you'd do that?
- I would not tell you no.
That'd be the most expensive soda
you've probably ever bought.
- That's an expensive Squirt.
How many places make friend chicken here?
- Oh we make the best fried chicken.
- Prove it.
(laughs)
- [Zack] Oh someone
didn't flush their pee.
- I didn't know how to flush.
- [Zack] You left your pee in their Chris?
- I pressed this.
- [Zack] Chris this is the
nicest place we've ever been,
you can't,
- I don't,
how do you flush?
(men shout)
- [All Chant] Nic, Nic,
Nic, Nic, Nic, Nic.
- So we're gonna head to the bedroom.
We're gonna make this a
true Chicken Watch moment.
- Chicken Watch moment.
- Good crispiness.
It's got a crunch like a drum.
- I'm giving it a sexy nod
because look at how that looks.
- It's beautiful.
- This is the most beautiful
chicken ever I think.
- This is beautiful as Hughie
Stone Fish is right now.
(dings)
- This is one of the best I've ever had.
Chicken Watch!
- Chicken Watch!
- Vegas Edition.
- Chicken Watch moment.
- This is the first time I'm
meeting some of Keith's friends
and there's this cool thing
happening where like old friends
are becoming new friends,
and new friends feel
like they're old friends and we're all
just one big happy Keith family.
- I'm getting crumbs all
over this expensive ottoman.
(magic sparkles)
- [Ned] I know that you really
like pinball, so we are going
to the pinball hall of fame.
- What, what?
- He loves pinball?
- What, don't you know I love pinball?
I think my love of pinball originates
from the Sesame Street pinball intro.
- I was lying.
Surprise motherfucker.
It's dicks.
- Australian Thunder From
Down Under is a show,
its a, we all start out in costumes
that we think women might find appealing.
We work our way down from there.
We're gonna teach you
a few dance moves today
which Keith might be able
to use on his wedding night,
spice things up you know.
- Oh yeah, it's pretty vanilla I'd say.
(laughs)
They taught me a little bit of moves
so I can impress Becky in
the bedroom on wedding night.
- So you go one, two,
you go around and down.
- Like I'm ready to
poop right on the floor.
- Ready to poop.
- Yeah I got you.
- Gonna show her what's happening later.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
(laughs)
- There's no sorry.
There's no sorries in that step.
Slide step, back spin.
- Suck it.
- And then the suck it.
- You got all these sexy Aussie men.
I became a sexy Aussie man myself.
- So I think it's time
that you actually practice,
practice on someone, ready
for your wedding night,
what do you reckon?
- Uh yeah, I could find
a good Becky lookalike.
- [Guy] Marc let's get you up there.
- Oh my god.
(cheers and applause)
Oh my god.
(dings)
Wow.
So I met Keith in 2006, we ended up
in the same improv group
in college and I believe
he was playing French
horn and singing some sort
of offensive song and
I remember walking away
going like, that guys was really funny but
I don't know if that's okay.
This is just what Becky's hair looks like.
This is perfect.
- This is such a close
resemblance to my beautiful bride.
She'll be thrilled about this.
(dance music)
(men cheer)
I got to be onstage with the
pros, ripping my shirt off,
amongst some gorgeous men.
(cheers)
- Oh my.
- And I feel bad for them because (scoffs)
I got a nice torso.
(cheers and applause)
So, now what?
- We are changed and we
are ready for yet another
surprise for Keith.
(dance music)
- Where are we going in the pool?
- Oh you'll see.
(dings)
Keith loves to see his name,
he loves to hear his name,
and Vegas is all about
spraying his name everywhere.
- [Ned] Do you ever watch
like MTV Spring Break?
This was that, but in Vegas.
- [Zack] It felt like
a god damn music video.
People are splashing around,
everyone's looking hot
in bathing suits.
- [Ned] Have a private
cabana reserved for us
including bottle service,
some tasty snacks
and a few Keith related surprises.
- And then they bring fried chicken wings.
I'm eating so much fried
chicken, its great.
And then they take me to the DJ booth.
The man says, it's Keith inside the,
most people don't know who I am,
so I just start fucking dancing.
Best part, I get to do
the (imitates bullhorn)
And I also get to hit the big
button that for some reason
shoots fog out of the DJ.
- [Zack] Everyone went fucking nuts.
(pulsing music)
- [Eugene] This was a
lot of bottle service.
- My favorite memory of Keith
is also my worst memory of Keith.
(dings)
The one night we're
talking about the influence
of John Philip Susa on
the culture of America.
Keith got so upset, stripped
naked, penis and balls
and everything in front of my girlfriend
and threw that chair of my apartment,
right through that screen door that I had.
He loves his American marches.
- Just when I think, you
know, it's winding down,
maybe we should start heading,
the entire crew of bikini
clad women come back
and they're like, Keith,
go stand in the pool,
I'm like, okay, great,
I'll stand in the pool.
- [Chris] They literally surrounded him.
Like a goddamn champagne
bukkake and just sprayed.
- [Ned] And Keith, dancing,
getting showered in Champagne.
- The first five seconds
are like, woo champagne,
the next 30 seconds are,
I'm gonna drown (laughs)
and just when I think it's done,
one last lady just pours
one more bottle directly
onto my face and I'm
like who's doing this,
why would this happen to me,
it's supposed to be my day.
That was a huge waste of champagne.
(laughs)
Vegas baby.
- [Camera Man] Guess what Keith,
we're not even close to done.
(men cheer)
(chant Keith)
- So what do you do to follow up
one of the most insane pool parties ever?
- Time for the boys to suit up.
(sings doowop)
- Boo.
(laughs)
- My name's Jamal Taherzadeh
I'm the executive chef
at the Libertine Social at
Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas.
We have unlimited resources
to get any product on earth
and incredibly fresh.
It's almost like the opposite
of what happens in the rest
of the country, what makes
this restaurant special
where everything's all about
local and sourcing everything
not a lot of food grows in Las Vegas
so we have to get really creative.
- This is a tuna cone.
- This is my favorite, I could
eat this for dinner everyday.
- Wow, that's tremendous.
Third fried chicken of the day.
Jesus.
- What Keith doesn't know
is that the signature dish
will be prepared by me.
The steak is from an American Wagu cow
that's the same cow
that's used in Kobe Japan
to make Kobe beef.
- I hope they taste good,
otherwise I'm like ruining
a very expensive cut of meat.
- There you go.
(shouts)
Just a super unctuous, rich,
delicious, almost like creamy.
It burns at like 750 degrees,
so prepare to be uncomfortable
by how hot it is.
- Woo,
ugh.
My face is on fire.
Oh man.
- [Jamal] Be aggressive.
(grunts)
Don't hesitate, get the ones
all the way in the back.
We grill some mushrooms, we're
using mitake mushrooms today.
That gets tossed in a truffle viniagrette
with soy sauce, lime juice,
some radish, fresh herbs.
- If my coworker Stephen
Linn taught me anything
it's that this dish needs truffle.
(dings)
- Let's do our smoke gun.
And now you can see the
smoke starts coming out.
- Get it baby, get it baby.
- More, more, more, more more.
(dings)
Unleash it there you go.
Okay, that's good, okay.
- Truffle.
Do you ever just take
this for recreational use?
- Yeah.
- I'm Tony Abou Ganim principle
mixologist and partner here
at Libertine Social.
And I've got something really
special for the groom to be.
It's our summertime swizzle.
I'll need a couple of volunteers
to help me make up some pitchers.
(laughs)
- Why is mine spilling, wait, what what?
- Swizzle, swizzle quick Zack.
- Why is mine the only
one that's spilling?
(laughs)
- There you go.
Up and down.
- Up and down, there you go.
- Like that there?
- No not like that there.
Yours is perfect.
- Looks like his,
- Zack's gonna be a little
watered down because
he overswizzled.
- I really thought I
was gonna do a good job
and I just swizzled all over the place.
- Oh yeah, I'll take yours and not Zack's.
(laughs)
- [Men] Cheers.
(cheers and applause)
- Now I put extra truffles
on it for you bachelor boy.
- I see that.
I think Ned was just trying
to sky rocket this bill
a little higher and just
throw money on the plate
for me to eat.
That is so good.
Oh my god that beef is so good.
It worked, I ate it.
Bell-a-gio.
Goodness me.
- [Guy] All the surprises so far
we're a little bit of foreplay,
the climax though is when we take Keith
to Hyde, at Bellagio.
- We have the best view
in all of Las Vegas.
This entire section is ours,
we have some very good
alcohol coming our way
so drink up enjoy, the
night is yours my man.
- Thank you very much.
Thank all you guys for coming out,
for making this so fun.
Appreciate it.
(cheers and applause)
- I first met Keith in 2009.
I have twin girls, Keith
and his fiance Becky,
would come over and watch
my daughters every Thursday.
He spent a lot of time,
helping me and just being a good friend.
- [Eugene] Keith thinks that this table
was his special treat
and he's all excited,
he's having a good time.
- Then they bring out this
$250,000 bottle of champagne.
What is this?
what a waste!
Cheers guys, thanks for coming out.
(cheers)
That's some absurd bottle.
Giant bottle of champagne,
a gorgeous view,
what could be better?
Then they bring out,
this like fancy button.
Kind of looks like a doomsday device.
- As part of your package
you get to select a song
to set off the fountains at Bellaggio.
(laughs)
By pressing this magical button.
- What?
- You can pick any song you want.
And when you press that
button, the song will start
and the fountains will go.
- This is the first time,
I've ever been given
a red button, a button
that like, makes decisions
that effects peoples lives,
that will change the course of history.
So I do what any level headed person does.
Santa Baby.
- It's Christmas in July baby.
(cheers and applause)
- The staff is confused.
And we're not allowed to play that song.
(laughs)
- I thought he could
pick any song he wanted,
but Christmas in July, I get,
maybe that is half a million dollars,
we were only paying a
quarter million dollars.
- So I picked Ho down by Aaron Copeland.
- [Zack] We all counted down
and he gently splat that button
and the fountains erupted.
(screams)
And you know that below, all of Las Vegas
was sharing in our experience.
- [Guy] We just kind of got to
have just a moment of peace.
Looking at the fountains.
- It felt like the end of Ocean's 11.
It was like the most
magical moment of my life.
Until I get married.
- This is awesome, whoa.
(cheers)
- I think the nights
done, then we turn around
the Bellagio restaurant
has turned into a club.
- Now let's party.
- Let's party hard.
(shouts)
- We at the same place
but it looks different.
There's a screen that
goes up, a DJ comes out,
lights, dancing, and we're
all of a sudden in a club
and then from there it's a blur.
- [Guy] We go fucking hard
for the rest of the night.
- [Zack] There's just lasers everywhere,
there's a bridal party
and we hang out with them
then we go later bridal party,
we got other places to be.
- So then we go to Lights, which of course
lots of lights.
(dings)
we have another table for some reason,
- [Ned] we're just partying
to make Keith even more happy.
I had a special idea at the club.
- [Keith] They said Keith turn around.
And I turn around, and
the screens have my name
raining down on them.
- Its like at the end of
solitaire on Windows 95
when all the cards like bounce everywhere.
Except for it's just Keith.
He was so happy it was
just, it was all worth it.
- [Zack] And then we go to Hakkason.
Hakkasan was just another planet.
- [Keith] And Tiesto,
that famous DJ, he's DJing
so we're dancing, they gave us
these bracelets that light up
the whole crowd lights up.
(dance music)
- [Friend] Good morning
Keith how do you feel?
(hums)
(crunches)
- [Zack] I feel depleted.
- [Keith] I didn't sleep enough.
- I think Vegas
took a little part of
me and clawed into it
this is mine I'm keeping it.
When you are in Las Vegas you get
to feel like you're royalty.
It is a city designed to
make you feel awesome.
And to allow you to live in a fantasy
if only for a day.
It was a special experience
because it was all about Keith
and it was about friendship
and it was about brotherhood.
We love Keith.
- [Guys] We love Keith.
- [Marc] You know Keith is
such an amazing performer
such an amazing guy.
- Keith is a great person
to collaborate with,
to hang out with, to be friends with.
- I'd encourage him to keep his spirit
of improvisation and his
spirit of spontaneity.
- I think the most
important thing he can do
in his marriage is find the
times that Becky's the star.
- I think Keith doesn't
need that much advice,
he's very good with relationships,
everybody likes Keith.
I think he's gonna be great.
(jazzy music)
- Now Keith's gonna be
married, I'm also married
and Eugene has dogs so
like, I need a thing,
guess I gotta have a baby or something.
(whooshes and squeaks)